well Iranians living in Ukraine are
demanding that their government stops
supplying Russia with attack drones
Ukraine says that it's shut down
hundreds of Iranian drones launched by
Moscow Tehran insists that it is not
providing Russia with the weapons
the blood of ukrainians is on your hands
the cry from Iranian protein
produce drone attacks in Ukraine
continue keeps Western allies including
the European Union and the United States
claim Iran is supplying the weapons
this is especially painful for us the
Iranian people living here the country
we were born in and the regime now in
power is sending drones to kill us our
friends and acquaintances in cues
Iran denies that it's producing the
drones which have become a key weapon
for Russia in the past month the
Invaders have often used them to Target
crucial energy infrastructure Ukraine
has been pushing back
[Music]
from September 13th when the first
Shahid 136 Kamikaze drone was shot down
until today we have shot down more than
300 Shahid drones
[Music]
ending alongside one of the downed
weapons President Vladimir zielinski
says 30 drawings were sent by Russia in
two days with Defense Forces shooting 23
of them down
the Ukrainian government has given Iran
a formal demand to stop supplying the
drones to Russia
well for more on this I spoke with Mark
cansey and earlier he is a retired U.S
marine Colonel he's now a senior advisor
with the center for strategic and
international studies in Washington I
asked him what we know about the drones
that Russia is using in Ukraine
the most plentiful drawn seems to be
this Shaheed 136
like a cruise missile uh it is a
Kamikaze drone it's fired once it's
Guided by GPS it has a pretty long range
but it flies low and slow so it's very
vulnerable that's why the ukrainians
have been able to shoot so many down
but Russia is using them because they're
running out of cruise missiles they
fired many during the war their ability
to produce more is quite limited uh so
they've gone to these uh Iranian
um uh drones and how can we be sure that
it is Iran that is providing these
drones
well remember when a drone or a cruise
missile explodes it doesn't disappear
the wreckage is still at the site of the
explosion and there are lots of pictures
online uh showing wreckage from these
drones and you can see that they match
the kinds of drones that Iran has
fielded Iran has not hidden these drones
they've showcased them they're very
proud of their drone program so you can
see what they produce and then you can
see the records it's clearly uh the same
weapon and you know if this is true then
obviously we've got Iran violating the
the arms export embargo that the West
has imposed upon it but this what does
this tell us about Russia the fact that
Russia is turning to Iran for weapons
well Russia is hard up for uh Munitions
Ukraine is getting them from the United
States and NATO but Russia doesn't have
a very good source they've gone to North
Korea now they've gone to Iran they can
produce some domestically but uh very
limited you have to keep in mind that
Wars require a continuous stream of
weapons and Munitions to keep armies in
the field Ukraine has its supplies from
U.S and NATO Russia is scrambling to
keep its Army supplied
and Russia says that it has completed
its call up of up to 300 000 military
reservists so what does that mean then
overall for Russia's strategy in Ukraine
right now I mean are these is this the
final call-up reservist that Russia can
pull from
well first I I doubt that they've called
up all three hundred thousand that would
double the size of their army I know
shoigu made that claim maybe they've
sent out notices uh but it takes a lot
of time to call that many reservists up
given the small size of the arm Russian
army beforehand nevertheless some of
them are clearly getting to the front
lines the Russian intention is to beef
up its forces they've taken a lot of
casualties many units were ground down
uh way on the strength bringing in these
additional Personnel will bring these
units up to strength their strategy is
not to go back on the offensive uh
they're not trying to regain the
initiative but what they will try to do
is to hang on to what they have
prevent any further Ukrainian advances
and extend the war into the winter their
hope is that the the Europeans will
crack under cold weather inflation
recession High Energy prices and and
that the European populations will
demand a ceasefire that would help
Russia in the long term
Mark Hansen with the center for
strategic and International Studies Mr
Canton we appreciate your time and your
insights tonight thank you
thanks for having me on the show